This video went viral recently after
it was uploaded to Twitter by a
pro-labor advocacy group called
More Perfect Union, which then
pointed the finger at the National
Restaurant Association, a lobby
group funded by big food
corporations, calling it a
key driver behind new bills,
letting kids work dangerous jobs.
Sure, taking drive thru orders
and slinging waffle fries at a
Chick-fil-A your dad owns sounds
like the definition of danger
exactly like working
in a coal mine.
Over the past year to help deal with
labor shortages.
Several states have pushed for
legislative changes that would let
more teenagers work.
New Jersey enacted a bill allowing
16 year olds to work up to 50
hours a week during summer break
with parental approval.
In Ohio, the legislature is
considering a proposal that would
make it possible for 14 and 15
year olds to work longer hours
during the school year.
And it's one of the few policies
Democrats and Republicans in the
state legislature agree on.
Last month, Arkansas Governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders signed a bill that
eliminated a requirement that 14
and 15 year olds obtain a permit
before getting a job.
These bills don't primarily benefit
the big food lobby, as the
union backed group that posted video
claims. And it's not an evil plot
to exploit children for profit.
The people who stand to benefit most
are actually teenagers themselves,
who, by having a job, can learn to
show up on time, follow
instructions, work collaboratively
and manage money that they earned
themselves, and therefore value
it more. "I feel as if I've learned
so much from this simple job over
the past few years," one teen
who worked as a ski instructor wrote
to the New York Times for a 2022
piece about the reality of holding a
part time job while going to school.
"I've learned how to work with
children, become a better teacher,
and how to help different people
based
on how they learn new skills." "My
job has helped me personally in many
ways. I was super shy before
I started and now I am more
confident,"  added another high
school student who is working five
days a week after school.
"I learned time management so that I
can get from school to work and then
come home and do homework." There's
plenty of data that backs up the
claim that holding a job as a teen
has positive effects.
A 2016 paper published in the
Southern Economic Journal, for
example, found that high schoolers
working 20 hours a week during their
senior year had 12%
higher earnings in their careers
than those that didn't.
Although that wage premium has
declined over the years for
complicated reasons.
In a job, teens are forced to
discover or build out parts of
themselves that are not required for
school, home or sports, psychologist
Lisa Damour told The Washington Post
last year. She also stressed that
having a job teaches kids to answer
to adults who aren't their parents
because when they do the same thing
over and over, there's no need to
grow. We need to stop treating
teenagers as inherently fragile
or they'll become that way.
Real world exposure to the challenge
of getting paid to do things that
other people value will benefit
them for the rest of their lives.